I recently shared with you that I'll be
quitting my college career to homeschool
I'm incredibly blessed that my husband
has always supported me in this desire
but this decision will take away our
only stable income and our health
insurance
thankfully through minimalism we've been
downsizing and finding ways to save more
and purchase less
but now that our budgets will be cut
dramatically I've been thinking of ways
that we can cut our expenses even
further
so today I'll be sharing with you the 12
ways that I plan to save more money
after quitting my full-time job
no we're not planning on selling our
house and living in a van by no means
are we going to Extreme Measures but
hopefully these ideas will be helpful to
you if you could use a bit more cash in
your savings
hey I'm yesi on this channel we talk
about minimalism and slow living if
those topics sound interesting to you
make sure you hit that subscribe button
so you won't miss when I post a new
video and be sure to stick to the end
for the tip that has been the most
helpful for me when it comes to saving
and meeting our financial goals first up
is to fix before buying in a recent
video I shared with you that we plan on
selling our large bedroom set in an
effort to downsize and make some money
off of it
and as I was going through items in our
home I realized that we've saved a lot
of money from first looking at fixing
items rather than immediately buying
that new item as an example our lamps
are not necessarily my style but they
were free to us because they were broken
and cracked so what I basically did was
I placed putty over them I chalk painted
them and ta-da you wouldn't even know
that these were broken to begin with
recently my camera gave me the black
screen of death after I dropped the lens
I searched through tons of videos and
did everything that I could to
troubleshoot and I learned that the
crown had popped out of place because I
had busted the crown I actually did
manage to revive it long enough to film
one video but I say all of this because
the important thing here is that my
instinct now is to try to fix something
before immediately heading to the store
or logging onto Amazon to buy that
replacement so the next time you break
something first think about can I fix
this and maybe look at some ways that
you might possibly be able to fix it who
knows you might save yourself major cash
doing this number two is changing phone
and internet service provider this one's
a really simple one and I've actually
wanted to do this for a while now but
because part of my job requires me to
work remotely it required things like
GPS hotspot and fast internet none of
which my job reimbursed me for but
nonetheless required now that I won't
need these I can switch providers in
order to save more money I found two
alternate companies in between both of
them we should be saving 85 dollars a
month if you personally like the company
that you're working with even just a
quick phone call saying that you're
considering switching to another company
maybe asking for discounts or whatever
offers that they might have is worth a
shot a lot of times you may be be able
to get a discount from them if you just
call and ask what's the worst that can
happen they say no you're already paying
the same amount you were to begin with
so give it a shot number three is to
downgrade your phone data plan so maybe
you want to keep your phone and your
internet service provider but do you
really need that super ultra unlimited
package or can you maybe go with a
little bit less I will be eliminating
our hotspot since I won't need that
anymore but I also plan to downgrade
that unlimited service as a sort of
challenge to myself to reduce my
internet usage because I already have
Wi-Fi at home I really don't need those
fancy packages number four I'm actually
super excited about this one is selling
my personal vehicle I've mentioned
before that both my husband and I have a
personal vehicle and up until now it's
been necessary because we both currently
I still work have full-time jobs with
very sporadic schedules but now that
that's going to change I'm super excited
to sell my vehicle because this will
cause a Cascade of other savings having
a vehicle means that you have to pay for
maintenance Insurance oil changes tag
fees car washes X Etc often our vehicles
and having more house than we can pay
tend to be the biggest culprits when it
comes to slowing down our savings number
five is to eliminate storage unit costs
I want to read a statistic to you that I
read that just about threw me out of my
chair according to 2018 statistics there
are more than 23 million storage units
in the United States
that's one for every 14 Americans that
was in 2018 I can't even imagine what
the statistics would say currently and I
get that sometimes it's necessary to
have a storage unit especially if you're
going to be moving for example but more
often than not that tends not to be the
case and storage units just end up
storing stuff that we don't know what to
do with or that we just want to put off
but we end up paying for it every single
month we're paying money to store our
stuff when potentially we could perhaps
sell these items via online or different
ways of selling them and make some money
off of them so eliminating storage unit
costs could be a great way to not only
sell in order to make more money off of
those items that you have stored away
but also reducing that monthly expense
number six is to opt for virtual classes
versus in-person classes When comparing
the cost of a course or a class of
course it's important to consider the
cost of the actual class but sometimes
what we fail to consider is the time
that it takes us to actually get ready
to drop off kids to drive there and back
and the gas money for it the job that
I'm leaving has mandatory meetings every
single month that I don't get paid for
and call me a horrible employee but I
never went to those meetings if I had
time I called in and listened because in
my mind it's not just the 30 minutes to
an hour it's all that I mentioned before
and I wasn't getting paid for it anyway
now granted meetings are something that
most of us don't enjoy anyway but you
can also apply this for things that you
do enjoy so for example maybe finding an
online workout versus in person if that
works for you that is or finding
whatever course that you want to learn
online an example for me is I definitely
need to learn about photography because
I kid you not sometimes it's taken me up
to an hour to take a thumbnail photo
because it's too blurry it's too bright
or it's too dark all this stuff about
aperture and shutter speed I it sounds
like foreign language to me so I
definitely need a photography class or
course but you better believe I'm going
to be hitting those free tutorials right
here on YouTube
while we're on that topic I'd love to
hear in the comments what is something
that you have learned for free here on
YouTube let me know in the comments
below number seven is cheap
entertainment in my search for cheap
stuff I had become aware of so many
events locally that I had never even
heard of things like parades for
different holidays Arts festivals and
free light shows during Christmas Even
our library has an event calendar with
free activities for both children and
adults and of course there's always a
good old picnic at the park or the
backyard
entertainment does not have to cost
anything
my absolute favorite entertainment is
hiking and walking along trails and it's
completely free
so check out your community's event
calendars and free resources
number eight I shop and sell kids
clothes at consignment shops I've been
purchasing used clothes for me and for
my family for a while now but one of the
things that I've started to do recently
is selling our kids clothes at a
consignment shop so basically what I've
been doing is selling the items that
they don't need anymore for whatever new
items that they might need I get money
back for those old items to put towards
the new items making their clothes super
cheap and sometimes even free
there are also lots of online groups
that swap old kids clothes and of course
thrift stores are a great option number
nine is ordering groceries online though
I've been criticized by the older
generations for taking the easy or the
lazy route when it comes to mundane
things like grocery shopping I am
definitely a fan of ordering groceries
online and using the pickup option
because I can still use my coupons I can
shop for the sales and I can avoid any
random purchases made out of curiosity I
find that for me buying groceries online
makes me much more conscious of a budget
because I'm actually seeing the total as
I'm adding items so it's basically
adding up as I'm shopping rather than at
the end while I'm at the checkout
counter wondering how in the world my
total got so high number 10 is having a
garden and drying your own herbs every
year we've had a garden and sometimes we
end up having Surplus so I recently
learned how to can veggies and I was
shocked at how easy it was to do and why
I had never done it before
having the skill of being able to garden
and grow our own veggies means that we
reduce a category that for a great
majority of us tends to be a pretty big
category for expenses
and not only that but learning how to
can means that we'll be able to have
veggies and food for a longer period of
time
and personally I found that even though
I had very little skill when it came to
gardening a few years ago I found that
herbs were actually pretty easy to grow
and drying your herbs means that you're
not having to constantly buy these items
you don't have to be an expert Gardener
but the more you practice at it the
better you will get number 11
simplifying hair care and skin care as
far as my skin care regimen it's very
very minimal it's pretty much coconut
oil that's pretty much about it but
about a year ago I finally took the
plunge at trying something that I had
wanting to do for a while and I dyed my
hair Balayage style basically I bleached
like the bottom ends of my hair and I
had no clue that this was going to
require a lot of Maintenance I just
figured you bleached the bottom it grows
out and you're done no no you have to
buy special shampoos and it requires
tinting and all these things that I
didn't know I was getting myself into
that was not for me I'm glad that I
tried it but now I know that that was a
mistake and it was definitely not for me
so as you can tell I've dyed my hair
dark again and I do not plan on buying
any more special shampoos and even
conditioner for the that matter before I
had dyed my hair I actually did never
use conditioner I would place a coconut
oil hair mask on my hair about once a
week before my shower and it helped keep
my hair nice and soft and shiny and
healthy so no more complicated skin care
or Hair Care regimens for me number 12
is to split the cost of bulk items since
I'll be home more it means that I'll be
cooking a lot more and one of the things
that my mom and I have actually done for
a while is that will actually split
certain items that we don't think that
we're going to be going through so she
has a Sam's Club membership there's
others like Costco and other stores that
basically sell in bulk and we basically
just split certain items so like for
example if you don't think that you're
going to finish this huge tub of oatmeal
you can split the cost with somebody
else or you can do what I do and just
totally mooch off of my mom's Sam's Club
membership because she pays for it and I
just get the cheap toilet paper
small and lastly as a bonus for sticking
to the end is delayed gratification with
a spin delayed gratification just means
that we recognize that we want something
but we force ourselves to wait just like
an adult horse as a child to wait after
dinner before eating dessert where I
have used this to my advantage is that I
set a financial goal with a deadline and
if and only if we meet that goal then I
can buy a particular item that I've been
wanting but it's not a necessity
so for example I had wanted a Vitamix
blender for a long time because I can
make soups with it ice cream and super
creamy smoothies with seeds like flax
and chia completely pulverized but I
made a deal with myself that I could
only buy one if we paid off our debt by
a certain date the blender then became a
prize a constant reminder when I went to
the store and I wanted something that
there was something else that I really
wanted that would actually serve me for
years down the road
so instead of going for the pointless
pack of gum I would put that towards my
goal with the prize in mind my Vitamix
so for me doing this it's ultimately a
way of keeping me on track with my
financial goals and keep me motivated
but it's also a reminder that it's okay
to spend my hard-earned money on larger
purchases that I may otherwise feel
guilty for buying
I think unfortunately sometimes when it
comes to saving money we can go to
extremes we can go to the extreme of
we're saving too much and then we're
feeling guilty if we're actually making
a purchase that will make us happy or we
go to the other end and we're spending
so much money when we don't even know
what our statements are on our credit
cards for example so for me delayed
gratification really kind of keeps me
away from just buying things without
really paying attention to what I'm
purchasing but also allows me to
remember that it's okay to spend my
money and it's okay to give myself a
treat every now and then if I'm meeting
certain goals I thank you so much for
watching this video and if you liked it
please give it a thumbs up and help
support my channel also be sure to let
me know your great savings tips down in
the comments below so we can all learn
more ways to save more money I'll see
you in the next one bye for now